the same she just wanted to be alone you  know I feel so hopeless very I don't  have any answers and I'm just sitting  here  no after zoom broke my back just having  Joe there with me it made me feel safe  protected that's what you're doing in  there don't worry I couldn't protecting  our daughter  how are you is everything okay  everything will be okay when we stop  seeking it  right now what I need to do is gather up  all the metahumans that are on his list  okay but buried you realize that you're  the one who put most of them behind bars  they're not gonna trust the flash no but  I think I know someone that way go  I'll get narsing  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]